La solution de la société arabe vinayak vient jusqu'à
muy duro massacres d'une enquête par mois
l'oncle cool marmottes olympiques de tous
a obtenu la chatte personnelle
parce que quand nous achetons aux enfants
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour Bella est connue pour être très
progressiste et pour  tant qu'ils peuvent
accueillir des femmes, ils le feront même si leur
pleine capacité est comme un chaos contrôlé,
tout l'hôpital fonctionne toujours
malgré le manque de ressources et
tout a toujours le système pour moi
c'était une communauté de femmes sur
ces lits  à ce moment fugace et comment
ils forment vraiment cette communauté de
soutien les uns dans les autres, nous avions
si peu et pourtant ils se soutenaient
de très nombreuses façons, comme émotionnellement,
pratiquement comme se prêter pour
leurs téléphones ou se donner à chacun que vous connaissez
nourrir les bébés de l'autre
[Musique]
Je veux dire que la situation, je pense, est le
produit de beaucoup de facteurs
pressions culturelles le rôle de l'
Église catholique est vraiment vraiment clé parce que l'
Église catholique est très puissante et
puis le manque d'éducation précoce beaucoup
de culture  et les pressions sociales sur
les femmes pour qu'elles aient des enfants, c'est un
rôle des femmes, je veux dire dans certains secteurs,
en particulier les secteurs les plus pauvres de
la société, ils ont des femmes parce qu'alors les
enfants sont votre richesse que d'une manière ou d'une autre l'
hôpital était même un répit pour eux
de leur vie à l'extérieur parce que  comme
quelqu'un l'a dit, ils n'avaient pas à
penser à quoi que ce soit ils avaient de la nourriture à manger,
peu importe ce qui était juste cette nourriture
leur toit au-dessus de leur tête leur
eau courante donc même s'ils étaient à
l'hôpital c'était un peu comme une
pause  de leur vie
[Musique]
le personnel qui s'assoit avec ces femmes
tous les jours, si patient et leur dit
non, vous n'êtes pas obligé, je veux dire, vous
n'avez pas besoin d'avoir la permission de
vos parents de votre mère, je veux dire, avez-vous
demandé la permission  quand vous avez eu des relations sexuelles, je parie que
vous l'avez fait et donc maintenant vous n'avez pas à demander la
permission de vous faire connaître un stérilet
mais il y a tellement de patience à faire les femmes
tellement patientes c'est incroyable donc elles sont
toujours elles savent toujours que le temps est
contre elles  bon surtout ils ont dit
on veut vraiment expliquer aux jeunes c'est
comme les ados qui viennent qu'ils sont
vraiment mais c'est eux qui ont le plus peur c'est vrai c'est eux
le plus tu sais ils
dépendent toujours des parents et des gens pour
leur dire  que faire de leurs bébés, vous
savez que bébé donne naissance à des bébés, c'est
vraiment ce que c'est